alors moi j'aime bien en général les
fresques donc j'aime bien cet aspect
monumental j'ai réussi à lire art as dit
mais je ne connais pas du tout cet
artiste
la quête aux nouvelles oeuvres de street
art dans le 20e arrondissement de Paris
une habitude pour Nathalie bourgeois de
Rick première présidente de chambre à la
cour d'appel de Versailles la magistrate
cultive une passion pour le street art
depuis une dizaine d'années j'aime
beaucoup me promener dans les villes et
ce qui m'intéressait au départ dans les
vignes c'est plutôt l'architecture au
fil de ces promenades je me suis un de
plus en plus aperçu qu'il y avait alors
des graffitis qui moi personnellement
m'intéresse moins mais aussi des des
fresques à ce moment-là Nathalie
bourgeois de Rick fait des recherches
livres et applications mobiles elle
développe sa passion pour le street art
en parcourant les rues des plus grandes
villes alors sur une ville comme
Bordeaux qui attaille un peu plus
humaine que Paris c'est vrai que moi
quand je vais à Bordeaux j'essaye de
voir ce qui est un artiste que beaucoup
qui s'appelle Charles froussard par
exemple que je vais aller rechercher
voir les oeuvres nouvelles qu'il a pu
qu'il a pu commettre dans Bordeaux j'ai
eu la chance de pouvoir aller aux
États-Unis parce que c'est aussi la
patrie du street art et notamment New
York ou Philadelphie quand elle n'est
pas enquête d'oeuvre d'art
urbain Nathalie bourgeois de Rick est à
la cour d'appel de Versailles depuis
septembre 2022 elle occupe la fonction
de première présidente de chambre auprès
du premier président Jean-François beneL
je vais avoir une double casquette en
fait je vais être à la fois magistrat
comme tous mes collègues avec des
audiences et puis je reste cette
casquette de d'animateur d'un d'un gros
service puisque j'aurai 21 chambres à
animer donc 21 x 3 vous faites le calcul
ça fait un certain nombre de magistrats
avec les le pôle civil classique le pôle
commercial le pôle social et le pôle
familier avec 30 ans d'expérience dans
la magistrature d'auditrice à la Cour de
cassation en passant par juge pour
enfants au tribunal d'Evry jusqu'à la
vice-président du tribunal de longs
jumeaux Nathalie bourgeois de Ric a
atteint le plus haut grade de magistrats
oriérarchie